Welcome back.
I'm now on page 460 and we'll
start with the number five.
And they have a little
drawing for us.
Let's see, if I had a little
box like that,
I'll do it in yellow.
So the box looks something
like this.
And then it has a
bunch of lines.
It has a line like that.
And then they have a couple
of points here.
They have-- let me switch
to the pen.
That's too dark.
So you have point
A, B, C, and D.
And the question is, in the
figure above, a path from
point A to point D is determined
by moving upwards
or to the right along the
gridlines-- so you have to
move along the yellow lines--
how many different paths can
be drawn from A to D that do
not include either B or C?
So we can't have either B
or C in our path that
goes from A to D.
So the way I think about it is,
which of the-- if we call
these yellow lines roads, I
guess-- which of these roads
would be unusable if I can't
go to B or to C?
Well, let me mark the
unusable roads.
Well, the unusable roads would
be the roads that their only
purpose is to get to B or go
away from B, or get to C or go
away from C.
So, for example, this road right
here, all it does is go
towards B or go away from B, so
we can't use that because
we're not going to
go through B.
Similarly, we can't use that
road, can't use this road, and
we can't use this road, right?
Because those are all the roads
that come to and from B.
So we're not going
to use those.
The only reason why you would
use those roads is if you went
through B, so you
can't use those.
And similarly for C, same thing,
you can't use that one,
can't use that one, can't
use that one, and
can't use that one.
So what are we left with?
We might as well just erase
those roads, right?
Because they're kind of just
messing up the picture, right?
So let me just erase them.
So let me erase all the roads
that I can't use.
I can't use any of these
because I can't go
through B or C.
And then it's going to start
looking a lot clearer.
Then the problem gets
really easy.
So these are all the roads I
can use to go from A to D.
So how many paths are there?
Well, that's one path, one.
I can do this.
Two paths.
Three paths.
Four paths.
And that's choice B.
I hope I'm right.
At least my choice exists.
Problem number six, if 3/7 of
n is 42-- so if I write that
algebraically, that's just
saying 3/7 times
n is equal to 42.
And they want to know what
5/7 of n is, so they
want to know 5/7n.
Well, to solve for n here, I
just multiply both sides times
the reciprocal.
So let me do that.
So 7 over 3-- I'm just
multiplying both sides of the
equation by 7 over 3.
So this cancels out, right?
So we could say n is equal
to 7 over 3 times 42.
And now we want to know 5/7
times n, so we just take this
n, place it here.
So it'd be 5/7 times
this thing-- right?
This is n-- times 7
over 3, times 42.
And notice, I just kept it that
way because the 7's ended
up cancelling out, so I have
to do less arithmetic.
So scratch those out.
And then let's see, five times
42 over 3-- let's see, what's
42 divided by 3?
It's what?
14, right?
Because 30 and 12.
Right, it's 14.
So this goes to 1, this goes to
14, and 5 times 14 is 70.
And that is choice A.
So all you do is you can
just solve for n and
then multiply by 5/7.
It's not too fancy.
This is probably one just to see
how fast can you do this
type of problem.
OK, clear image, invert.
All right, I'm on problem
number seven
and I'm getting sleepy.
I'm just going to go to
bed after this video.
All right, the figure
above-- well, let me
draw the figure above.
We have that, and then we don't
know what this figure is
for, just yet.
And then they say A,
B, C, D, E, and F.
And now let's read
the problem.
The figure above shows the top
view of an open square box
that is is divided into six
compartments with walls of
equal height.
Each of the rectangles D, E, and
F have twice the area of
each of the equal squares
A, B, and C.
So they're saying D is twice the
area of A, I guess, right?
The way I drew it, it looks
like a little more, but we
know this is twice the
area of this, OK.
When a marble is dropped into
the box at random-- so it's
kind of being dropped from above
into this box-- it falls
into one of the compartments.
What is the probability
that it will fall
into compartment F?
So the way you really just have
to think about it, the
marble has an equal
chance of falling
anywhere on this square.
And so, if you want to know the
probability that it falls
into F, you just have to figure
out the fraction of the
area that F is of the
entire square.
So if we said that A has an area
of x, then B also has an
area of x, and C also has an
area of x, and they told us
that these are twice these, so
this would be 2x, this would
be 2x, and this would
be 2x, so the total
area would be what?
It would be x plus x, plus x.
So 3x plus 2x, plus
2x, plus 2x.
So these three are 6x, so the
total area is 9x, right?
9x is the total area
of the box.
I mean, we don't know how big x
is, but 9x is its total area
of the box.
And F is 2x, right?
F is 2x.
So the area of F over total
area-- I don't like this
toothpaste blue color,
but we'll deal.
So the area of F, I wrote
here before I
scratched it out, is 2x.
Over the total area is 9x,
and the x's cancel out.
So F is 2/9 of this total box's
area, so there's a 2/9
probability that a marble
dropped randomly on top of
this box, with kind of a uniform
distribution anywhere
in the box, there's a 2/9
chance that it will
fall into cubby E.
Sorry, cubby F, that's what they
asked us in the question.
And actually, it would also be
2/9 that it would fall into
cubby hole E, because
it's the same area.
Problem number eight.
So if a and b are odd integers,
which of the
following must also
be an odd integer?
Oh, these are fun.
All right, so choice one they
give is a plus 1 times b.
Well, can this be odd?
Let's just try it with
some numbers.
Let's say a and b are
3 and 5, right?
These are two odd integers.
If a 3, then a plus 1 is 4,
times 5, this equals 20.
So we immediately, we ended
up getting an even answer.
And that makes sense, because if
you take an odd number, add
1, you get an even number.
And anything times an even is
even, so it's not going to be
choice one.
Choice one is going to give us
an even number, actually, no
matter what.
Choice two.
a plus 1 plus b.
So we figured out that a plus
1, this is going to be even,
and we know that b is odd.
And you could try this out, but
if you take an even number
and you were to add an odd
number to it, you're going to
get an odd number.
And that makes sense, I mean,
you could try it out with a
bunch of different numbers,
but that's
always going to happen.
Because if you add an even
number to an even number you
get another even number.
And then if you add one more,
an odd number-- I think you
get the point.
And you could try it out with
our 3 and 5 examples.
That wouldn't prove it for sure,
but it does work for
that example.
And then similarly,
a plus 1 minus b.
It's the same notion.
I mean, you could try it
out with some numbers.
But if you have an even number
here-- because an odd plus 1
is even-- and then if you were
to subtract another odd
number, you'd also get
an odd number.
So the choice is E.
See you soon.